music expresses that which cannot be put
into words
and that which cannot remain silent
it is from books that wise people derive
consolation in the troubles of life
the paradise of the rich is made out of
the hell of the poor
to put everything in balance is good
to put everything in harmony is better
[Music]
it is nothing to die
it is frightful not to live
not being heard
is no reason for silence
nothing makes a man so adventurous
as an empty pocket
laughter is sunshine
it chases winter from the human face
to love or have loved
that is enough
ask nothing further
there is no other pearl to be found
in the dark folds of life
to learn to read is to light a fire
every syllable that is spelled out is a
spark
reason is intelligence taking exercise
imagination is intelligence within
erection
certain thoughts are prayers
there are moments when whatever be the
attitude of the body the soul is on its
knees
[Music]
you who suffer because you love
love more
to die of love
is to live by it
you ask me what forces me to speak
a strange thing
my conscience
he who opens a school door
closes a prison
people do not lack strength
they lack will
there is nothing like a dream to create
the future
a man is not idle because he is absorbed
in thought
there is visible labor and there is
invisible labor
life's great happiness is to be
convinced we are loved
he was fond of books
for they are cool and sure friends
no army can withstand the strength of an
idea whose time has come
melancholy is the happiness of being sad
an intelligent hell would be better than
a stupid paradise
[Music]
there is always more misery among the
lower classes
then there is humanity in the higher
[Music]
love is the foolishness of men
and the wisdom of god
there is something more terrible than
the hell of suffering
a hell of boredom
what makes night within us
may leaf stars
[Music]
to die for lack of love is horrible
the asphyxia of the soul
let us study things that are no more
it is necessary to understand them
if only to avoid them
[Music]
it is not easy to keep silent when
silence is a lie
winter is on my head
but eternal spring is in my heart
[Music]
the soul helps the body and at certain
moments
raises it
it is the only bird that sustains its
cage
[Music]
not seeing people permits us to imagine
them with every perfection
[Music]
there are no weeds
and no worthless men
there are only bad farmers
[Music]
let us sacrifice one day to gain perhaps
a whole life
when you get an idea into your head
you find it in everything
diamonds are to be found only in the
darkness of the earth
and truth in the darkness of the mind
[Music]
nobody loves the light
like the blind man
what is said about men often has as much
influence upon their lives
and especially upon their destinies
as what they do
[Music]
for there are many great deeds done
in the small struggles of life
he did not study god
he was dazzled by him
love is the only future god offers
being good is easy
what is difficult
is being just
faith is necessary to men
woe to him who believes in nothing
[Music]
common sense is in spite of
not the result of
education
every bird that flies has the thread of
the infinite in its claw
[Music]
a one-eyed man is much more incomplete
than a blind man
for he knows what it is that's lacking
[Music]
curiosity
is gluttony
to see is to devour
[Music]
to love another person is to see the
face of god
even the darkest night will end and the
sun will rise
as with stomachs
we should pity mines that do not heat
[Music]
fashions have done more harm than
revolutions
is more imminent than the impossible
what we must always foresee
is the unforeseen
if you are bored alone with yourself
it means that you are in a bad society
life is a theater set in which there are
but few practicable entrances
[Music]
the realities of life do not allow
themselves to be forgotten
each man should frame life so that at
some future hour fact and his dreaming
meet
a man without a woman is like a pistol
without a trigger
it is the woman who makes the men go off
life is the flower for which love is the
honey
mother's arms are made of tenderness
and sweet sleep blesses the child who
lies therein
[Music]